When you look
at every little detail
in The Dark Crystal,
those things are
the apex of somebody's art.
There's so few people
that know
how we did it the first time,
and we're so old we don't
remember how we did it.
Everything is hand-sculpted,
hand-painted.
Just an amazing amount
of craftsmanship
that you see
across the whole image.
The first thing
you're trying to do
is live upto
what the film produced.
The next stage
is then to push it a lotfurther.
I think Jim Henson
would have been delighted.
Puppetry.
It's an art form in itself.
And that's
what you're watching.
I feel like Louis,
he's really the right person
to be standing
in my father's shoes.
The ideais that
you watch the show
and you forget
you're watching puppets.
Your destiny calls to you.